good afternoon i'm pleased to be joined
virtually this afternoon by minister of
health jason coppin and edmonton dr uh
hinshaw dr yu from alberta health and
albert health services um to offer an
update on the situation in alberta with
omacron and covet 19. i have some good
news to share but also a word of caution
the good news is that there are some
early indications that alberta has
reached and surpassed the peak of
infections in our province it's still
early days but we can see that in
of the 19 communities where we are doing
waste water analysis
we have seen in those samples and
studies that omicron and delta are
excuse me our covet 19 are declining in
15 of those 19 communities most
importantly with apparently significant
declines as of january the 16th in
calgary and edmonton the two
areas most uh or who were earliest hit
by the omicron wave
so that's encouraging uh there are still
four of the 19 communities where trends
are suggesting through wastewater an
increase in transmission um but let's
recall that uh omicron did not affect
all regions of the province
simultaneously so we can expect to see
some regional variances we've also seen
some evidence of the stabilization and
decline in the
pcr
a week ago today we were at a positivity
rate of 41
and uh for yesterday we're reporting 33
percent uh we'd obviously like to see
that trend continue but what we do know
looking around the world is that the
omicron waves of transmission have
typically peaked about four weeks after
they began and here in alberta we
we
went past the 50 of our covet 19 cases
being identified as omicron variant uh
on december 16th so we're now exactly
five weeks from that point really five
weeks from what we could define as the
onset of the omicron wave in alberta so
if the
virus if the variant performs in alberta
like it has in jurisdictions all around
the world we we can reasonably expect
that we may now be uh beginning on the
downslope of transmission uh having said
that there continues to be growing
pressure in our hospitals and we have to
be very mindful of that
particularly in
non-intensive care beds so regular ward
beds we now have a little over a
thousand patients admitted either for
or with a covet
in those beds
now we have been
doing a more detailed data analysis of
those admissions to determine what
percentage of those patients were
admitted for covet as their their
primary uh cause of hospitalization
versus those who were incidental cases
who were admitted and then subsequently
tested positive but are typically
asymptomatic and
basically what we're seeing over the
past week or 10 days
is that 45
of the non-icu covet
hospital patients um are
incidental cases
the covet is not the reason for their
hospitalization about 40 percent
are primary covet patients they were
admitted primarily because of covet and
then a small percentage um are admitted
where covid is not the main but is a
contributing factor they may have a
chronic condition that is worsened
potentially uh by covid so that is uh
that is i would say some good news now
point a word of caution um even if a non
even if a patient uh who is asymptomatic
for covid who is an incidental covet
patient is admitted to hospital um and
they subsequently test positive they do
need
they do need
additional
treatment protocols isolation staff have
a different standard in terms of
personal protective equipment so that
does those cases can add marginally to
the pressure on our hospitals uh more on
the good news side though i think partly
because of the the significant number of
incidental code cases and non-acute care
beds we've been quite stable at around
6300
total non-icu patients in alberta's 100
hospitals those are about a thousand
covid and 5300 non-covid patients in
ward beds
and that has been pretty stable for the
past week or 10 days
uh meaning that we're operating at about
89
of total capacity across our health care
system now
i know dr you will will hasten quite
rightly to point out that that is an
average and that some of our hospitals
particularly in calgary and edmonton are
much closer to 100 and are quite heavily
burdened
and i think based on the velocity of
growth we do know of course there will
be a lag between the peak in infections
and the peak and hospitalizations
probably something in the range of a
two-week lag
if we judge from many other
jurisdictions they haven't all performed
identically but that would seem to be a
reasonable expectation of about a two
week lag between the case peak and the
hospitalization peak um
and so i think we can reasonably expect
to see uh 1500 or more
uh covered patients in non-icu beds
when we reach the hospitalization peak a
little later in january again many of
them will be incidental cases but still
um with many healthcare workers having
to take time for self-isolation
themselves uh all of that will add
significant pressure uh to the health
care system i should add that
fortunately
uh the pressure really is being
experienced in the non-icu side of the
health care system
and as we expected we are not seeing uh
significant uh additional pressure uh on
intensive care as we did see during the
delta wave this has been a common
experience particularly with highly
vaccinated countries or countries with
high levels of population
uh protection uh with respect to to
intensive care so we have a little over
a hundred patients in intensive care um
with covid the last time i saw an
analysis about a week ago about half of
those were still dealt to patients um
who have been in hospital for a long
time
so a relatively small number of omicron
patients and about 30 percent of uh our
icu patients were admitted for
uh reasons other than
covetous and incidental finding
for them uh and so
again pressure certainly at over 200 uh
total uh patients in in icu something we
will we have to keep a very close eye on
but not the huge kind of pressure that
we were facing on intensive care during
delta
and so because of the expectation that
we're going to
see
potentially hundreds more non-icu
patients in our hospitals diagnosed with
covet
we are announcing today a number of
strategies that we have worked on as
contingencies if we reached a
significant pressure point i'm going to
outline those and minister copying
doctor you will detail these strategies
first of all we are building that
capacity in both non-icu and in io
as you settings existing beds are being
allocated for covet care and additional
beds are being opened in some locations
as needed and starting january 24th or
sooner
uh some beds in our pandemic response
units will be opened at the these are
units that we prepared earlier in the
covid period
for essentially overflow capacity if
necessary and they will be there really
to deal with patients who are ready for
um
ready to be
released from hospital but they may need
some additional
monitoring they may need they won't need
significant intensive care
but it is an additional measure that we
are taking uh just to be ready should we
get an a a a huge number of non-icu
patients in our hospitals
and one one additional thing i should
point out we are seeing a much shorter
uh period of hospitalization
for cova diagnosed patients uh in
alberta
in delta we saw that the period the
duration of hospitalization at about 10
days uh ahs is now reporting that at
about five days many other jurisdictions
are reporting an average a period of
hospitalization with covid omicron at
about 3.5 days so uh that that is also
um helpful in terms of managing capacity
the second
strategy that we are announcing today is
implementing a community response plan
through which a alberta health services
is closely working with primary care
networks to provide community resources
for those managing the illness at home
as the vast majority of coveted patients
do
well over 95 percent so ahs and our pcn
partners have opened or are planning
virtual call-in lines or coveted clinics
in select communities that will be
available to screen assess
and appropriately direct people with
mild and moderate cover 19
symptoms this is really important
because in some other jurisdictions
we've seen
that a large number of people coping
with kovid
who may not require hospitalization and
certainly don't require intensive care
may have minor symptoms but they're
showing up they're looking for tests
they're looking for a diagnosis they're
maybe they they maybe need um some some
kind of modest intervention and so we
want to avoid having a large numbers of
those people go to emergency wards um if
they don't have to go to emergency and
so i want to thank the family doctors
who across the province uh participate
in these primary care networks for their
flexibility in stepping up and helping
us to create these community clinics
um that can relieve hopefully some of
the current pressure from our hospitals
the third strategy that we're announcing
today to to maintain capacity is to
maximize the availability of the
workforce to support patient care and
through this alternative team based care
models are being implemented across the
province as necessary
this means that instead of individual
health care providers caring for a
smaller number of patients a team that
together has a complete skill set and
relevant experience collectively cares
for a larger group of patients and i can
say that six over 600 nursing students
have joined the ahs team and will work
and get educational credit for assisting
through this wave so i want to thank ahs
and everybody that works there for
helping to
roll out these strategies to cope with
omicron
let me say as an update on schools i'm
glad that to report that we only have
six out of the
2 400 k-12 schools in alberta that have
had to shift to online learning as a
result of covett right now
and that's a great credit to parents
teachers staff administrators our
partners in the school boards everybody
albert education that's been working on
this
to see
uh only six of 2400 schools that have
had to move to online instruction
and that means basically 99
of our schools are are operating for
in-classroom instruction
and doing so safely we know it's been
challenging we know with staff uh
uh isil many staff on isolation
on sick leave many students having to
stay home uh it has been challenged no
doubt about it but just thank you to
everybody for your flexibility and
patience and i know many parents are
frustrated um in some schools not yet to
have received rapid test kits i'm told
that the vast majority of schools have
received the test kits that we committed
to um but the reality is that we are
facing a global a massive global
shortage in these rapid antigen test
kits uh to date alberta has distributed
15.3 million
tests
now typically these they come in
packages of five but that's 15.3 million
tests since they first became available
um
and as you know we became
impatient with delays from uh the
federal government's promised deliveries
of rapid antigen tests and so we went to
market
in mid-december to procure 10 million
rapid tests directly from the by the
province
unfortunately we've been running into
the same
global
supply constraints and and just general
problems with supply chains around the
world
in fact i'm told by our
department of health that um one major
u.s provider with whom we signed a
contract had the u.s federal government
come to them
about 10 days ago and order a billion
tests
and basically to say use force measure
to say
that we take precedent over all
international orders so we are starting
to see we talked a year ago about
vaccine nationalism we're starting to
see that same kind of protectionism or
nationalism when it comes to these rapid
tests i think
this underscores once again the need for
us here in canada to onshore production
development of vaccines of therapeutics
but also
equipment like tests of this nature
it also underscores what i've been
speaking about since april of last year
the need for health canada to accelerate
the approval of additional rapid tests
as i keep pointing out in europe over a
hundred different tests rapid antigen
test products are available on the
market but we only have a handful i
think six or so here in canada
and so we are much more vulnerable to
these supply constraints as a result so
uh once again we urge as all the
premiers have done we urge health canada
to get with the program
to use emergency youth authorization
protocols to approve these tests these
are tests after all uh they're not
medical interventions um and
i i think it's reasonable that if
something has been deemed safe and
accurate for use in the european union
uh
that it should be uh that that should
count fit heavily in the favor of
applicants for approval by health canada
uh and so please to health candidate
let's get these tests more tests
approved so we can get them in the hands
of people
um
we are expecting although i say this
with some
with some caution because of all the
delays we've experienced we're expecting
about eight million uh tests to be
delivered this week and next from our
own alberta government procurement and
another million of that the feds promise
us now those will be used for priority
populations including the schools for
school kids um
long-term care workers uh uh first
nations uh that have been more
challenged by kovit for example and
other higher priority groups uh
unfortunately it's going to be a while
until we get access to enough tests to
to once again make them free on a large
scale to the rest of the country to the
rest of the province excuse me
i said the rest of the country because i
uh just got off a phone call with all of
the premiers through the council of the
federation
i want to underscore that
we have
reinforced our collective solidarity to
demand a very significant increase in
federal funding for health care through
the canada health transfer
i think what all canadians regardless of
their political perspectives
are coming to terms with in covid is
that
is that these capacity challenges that
we have been experiencing where canada's
health care system has been uh
had far fewer beds quite frankly to
field um than most other developed
countries
uh that points to some very serious
issues in our health care system
and um even though here in alberta we
have the most expensive health system in
the country even though we added 900
million to the baseline budget of health
last year and i can tell you we will be
adding more to the budget for healthcare
this year even though we put in nearly
three billion dollars in covet
contingency even though we have more
nurses uh and doctors working in alberta
than any at any point in our history
we're spending more on health care that
at any point in our history we have
still struggled to
cope with the capacity constraints posed
by kovit and that is just not acceptable
the province is provinces are funding 78
percent of health care costs and the
feds are funding 22 percent so the
provinces are you know when it started
how medicare was supposed to be a 50 50
deal now it's a three to one arrangement
and so our um united demand is for a 35
percent federal a portion of health
funding that would increase alberta's
share of the canada health transfer by
about
3.25 billion dollars and that could
make a huge difference in our ability to
avoid the kind of
capacity challenges we've been facing
here
uh i also want to speak to a couple of
other issues involving
uh
kovit and the federal government
one is with respect to the quarantine
for truckers uh that is being imposed
for those who are unvaccinated now i
understand i understand vaccine mandates
for workers in certain uh occupations
and indeed we have done that ourselves
and albert health services and alberta
public service with an option for
uh
regular rapid antigen testing
but i think we need to apply these
policies with a heavy dose of common
sense and common sense tells us that we
are at the peak of supply chain
constraints across north america around
the world huge inflation
and we can't afford
to lose potentially thousands of
truckers on our roads bringing groceries
up from the us and who knows maybe rapid
test kits as well
and so i you know the federal government
brought in a delay
um of a few months on this quarantine
requirement for unvaccinated uh truckers
who cross the border i would just say
please extend
that like use some common sense
don't i don't understand why
we would be so rigid about this and
similarly
on the requirement that they they have
now for pcr tests for
travelers arriving
on airplanes from abroad
those travelers already have to prove
that they are fully vaccinated they have
to have a negative pcr test before they
board the flight they have to go through
a symptom test
many of them would have taken a and they
had gotten a negative pcr test shortly
before traveling not long ago
and so
to add an additional burden for really
no
measurable positive public health effect
makes very little sense to me again
please i say to ottawa use some common
sense on this
we have right now several million
canadians with current active omicron
infections we will have several million
more
as the country comes down the curve
testing asymptomatic people twice
fully vaccinated asymptomatic people
twice creating lineups in airports uh
which could be a vector of transmission
makes no sense so on my plea to the
government of canada is on things like
the quarantine for uh
international truckers and these arrival
pcr tests please apply
some common sense
um
let me just close with uh i started with
the word of optimism but guarded guarded
optimism i should say
there is a
i know a lot of people are saying to me
and to the government rightly
understandably you know when are we
going to get out of this you see the
united kingdom
um that is uh dropping almost all of its
coveted restrictions or will do so
shortly um scott the scottish government
said that was the
uk government for purposes of england uh
the scottish government announced scene
that they they believe they went too far
and some of their policies did not help
to diminish spread
um
spain and portugal take uh are talking
about a radical change in approach
uh other jurisdictions doing the same
thing so we're being asked when when do
all of these restrictions and measures
come to an end
and my answer is uh
hopefully soon but we have to get past
this on the crime we've not yet reached
the peak in hospitalizations we have to
support our healthcare workers so if if
you're frustrated i get it
um
i we are we are all frustrated and tired
of this thing sick and tired of it but
please in your frustration think about
the hospital workers who day by day are
seeing more patients show up they are
working uh incredibly hard
to to keep people safe
to save lives and so let's be mindful of
them
but in the
long in the mid-term i i did see a
really interesting editorial published
this week in the lancet the prestigious
british medical journal and i just want
to quote from this from christopher
murray quotes
the impacts of future sarsko v2
transmission on health will be less in
the future of a broad previous exposure
to the virus regularly adapted vaccines
to new antigens or variants the advent
of antivirals and the knowledge that the
vulnerable can protect themselves
uh ensuring that future waves
will be much less impactful covet 19
will become another recurrent disease
the health system and societies will
have to manage for example the death
toll from omicron seems to be similar in
most countries to the level of a bad
influenza season in northern hemisphere
countries
after the omicron wave covet 19 will
return but the pandemic will not i
certainly hope that the lancet is right
about that we're not there yet
and so folks just please continue to be
diligent be careful think of our health
care workers uh and let's just get
through this thanks very much and with
that i'll invite mr copping to say his
remarks
and let's just get through this thanks
very much and with that i'll invite mr
copping to say his remarks
great thank you so much premier and uh
and good afternoon
everyone i'm pleased to join you
virtually today as i advised on twitter
on
monday i've tested positive for copa19
and i've been isolating at home since i
developed symptoms
it's what we ask of every albertan and i
want to thank everyone who has done
their part by following the rules to
help reduce the spread of covenant 19.
we know omicron is highly transmissible
far beyond anything we've seen up till
now
none of us wants to be responsible for
giving covet to someone who is at high
risk or works or lives with someone who
is
since becoming health minister my three
priorities have been building immediate
capacity health system
increasing vaccinations and preparing
our health system
to respond to more
effectively large-scale health crises
such as coven 19. now if anyone still
doubts the risk that omicron variant
poses as a premier just laid out we have
reached the highest number of
hospitalizations with coven 19 ever now
recognizing that omar khan is so
widespread and as indicated by the
premier we are tracking those who are
hospitalized for coalit and those who
are hospitalized with code
currently approximately 55 percent of
new non-icu admissions and 70
of new icu emissions are directly due to
coveted 192. the remainder of our
patients with coven 19
that is related to the emission
while these individuals may not be
directly receiving treatment for coca-19
it's important to note that they require
extra care to ensure transmission does
not occur which requires more resources
in the hospital but the nation still
matters we need to know when covet is
the direct reason for admission
that we can make a better estimate of
the impact and severity of the virus and
so we can better plan for the resources
we'll need to serve alberta patients
we've worked hard on that planning and
we need to keep adapting as the virus
changes
as dr you pointed out in an op-ed
published
earlier this week
any albertan with covet 19 who has
needed admission to hospital over the
past two years has received it that
despite the immense pressures that covet
19 has put on our system
and as the premier said we are working
with ahs on three main areas to ensure
the health care system can continue to
respond to the growing needs that are a
result of omicron
increasing bed capacity
implementing a community response plan
and maximizing the availability of the
workforce now dr you will speak more in
detail in this in a moment
but my message to to you and to everyone
watching today is that we will be ready
in addition to ensuring our healthcare
system is ready we are also relying on
rapid tests to help reduce the spread
we're working to maximize the supply of
rapid tests in priority settings like
health care facilities
continuing care shelters in schools
and continuing to distribute as many as
we can to the broader public as supply
permits
while access to rapid tests can help to
give many symptomatic albertans
knowledge and some peace of mind as well
its greatest impact is helping people to
quickly know that they have covet 19 so
they can start isolating even if they're
not showing symptoms
that's why we're doing everything in our
power to ensure we have a strong steady
supply of testing kits coming into the
province and getting into the hands of
albertans as quickly as possible
and i'm pleased to report that despite
the delays and receiving rapid test kits
from ottawa and our own manufacturers as
mentioned by the premier we have now
shipped the vast majority of the tests
and mass promise to schools
we are also expecting 3.5 million rapid
tests from our own direct procurement
this week and an additional 4.5 million
next week additionally the federal
government has confirmed shipment of one
million tests this week
all of this means that we should be in
good position to begin the second
distribution of tests and masks to
schools next week as planned
subject to additional availability of
supply
will continue shipments to pharmacies
and ahs sites however it may be towards
the end of the month before significant
additional tests are available for broad
public distribution
throughout the pandemic alberta has had
a strong rapid testing program before
providing tests to the general public in
december kids have long been available
through our employer and service
provider program
i would like albertans to be sure that
as we contend with supply delays and
this is happening around the world
we continue to prioritize the supply of
workplace tests to those who care for
our most vulnerable
this includes healthcare workers and
mobile outbreak units as well as
long-term care designated supported
living and hospice facilities
primary care child care
and community services that look after
vulnerable populations including
shelters and residential treatment
facilities we also need albertans to
continue to do their part and the single
best way they can do that is to get
vaccinated against copenhagen
the vaccines work against the omicron
variant especially third doses
there's been a steady uptake of booster
doses with nearly 39 percent of
albertans age 18 and older stepping up
to get their third dose since we started
administering boosters for all adults a
month and a half ago
that's good but we need to get this rate
higher
as covet 19 has proven time and time
again we can hope but not assume that
this is the last coven-19 variant that
we will see in alberta
and vaccinations still remain the best
way to provide protection so that when
the next variant comes it is far less
likely to pose a serious threat to us or
the capacity of our health care system
and that's why we're still strong
encouraging albertans to get all of the
doses they are currently eligible for
i also believe albertans need and
deserve support as they continue to make
decisions about vaccination no matter if
it's their first or fourth dose
this week alberta's vaccine hesitancy
advisory committee held their second
virtual meeting
this group will advise on how we can
improve immunization rates among those
who are hesitant to get a coven 19
vaccine
i look forward to working with this
diverse group of health professionals
youth indigenous health directors
community leaders and academics as we
continue to look for ways to be able to
get information to albertans and
increase the rate of vaccinations
now the omicron wave as indicated by the
premier is once again straining our
health system although differently from
the fourth wave
omicron so far does not threaten our icu
capacity in the way that delta did
instead is training our hospitals more
broadly
we know the numbers will continue to
rise from the cases we've seen in the
past few weeks we know these cases will
peak and and will come back down
and hospital missions will come back
down with them but we don't know exactly
when
the one thing that is certain is that
the next few weeks are going to be
challenging
we need to focus on the task at hand
which is to support ahs and our
healthcare workers to care for the
continuing surge of patients who need
care in hospital
i am grateful for to everyone working in
our hospitals and across our health care
system from ems to labs to family
doctors offices to our home care and
continuing care providers we need all of
you and we know you're tired you've been
through this for over two years and you
need to get back to caring for patients
in a more normal fashion and we all need
to get back to living more normally and
we will get there
we'll get there with the support of four
and a half million albertans who
continue to protect each other and the
healthcare system by getting vaccinated
and following the public health rules it
has been a long two years but as as
indicated by the premier we will get
past this wave
so i want to thank everyone for doing
their part and i now i'd like to invite
dr berner you from ahs to come to the
podium and speak more specifically on
our plans to be ready for the next
search
good afternoon
we're once again facing significant and
increasing pressure
on our health care system
while we have successfully faced down
other waves the speed at which omicron
is spreading through alberta and around
the world is controlled is concerning
in the past week we have seen
hospitalization numbers increase sharply
provincially the number of patients with
covid who require hospital care has
increased by about 40 percent
while for some the health effects of
omicron may be milder than the other
covet strains the impact on patients
their loved ones the health care system
and health care workers is significant
as the premier said there are currently
1131 albertans in hospital with covet
19.
and this week we reach numbers of total
hospitalizations with covid that is
higher than at any point during the
pandemic
fortunately the number of albertans in
isu is still well below the total number
of icu patients that we cared for
at the peak of the fourth wave which was
313.
despite the somewhat positive news we
are seeing signs that our icu teams can
expect to see more patients
needing their care in the coming weeks
in the past seven days the number of
patients with covet 19 in our icu has
increased by about 18 percent
our ems and emergency department teams
are also facing volume increases
of as much as 30 percent
calls to health link
are up to by more than 300 percent
compared to pre-pandemic times
the recent surges in hospital and icu
cases coupled with the fact
that we are seeing more of our own
health care workers
become sick or have to quarantine due to
isolation requirements
means that our health care system is
facing yet another serious challenge
i want you to know though
that i have every confidence that we can
meet this challenge
i know this because of the incredible
dedication
of our staff physicians and leaders who
have
and will continue to give everything
they can
to help albertans get through this
relentless pandemic
and we are beginning to see signs that
we may be reaching the anticipated peak
of cases
one thing is clear
the current wave is having a very
different impact on our health care
system than those previous
this is not another wave affecting only
the unvaccinated such as delta wave 4
while the risk of hospitalization and
severe outcomes is lower if you're fully
immunized we are still seeing
breakthrough cases
this really highlights need for everyone
to follow public health measures
stay home when not feeling well wear a
mask in public places and remain
vigilant at all times
it has been a long two years
but now is not the time to let your
guard down
it also highlights importance of the
booster
evidence is really clear
people with a third booster are much
better equipped to fight the virus and
should they contract to virus they do
not seem to get a sick
and while the pressure on our eds acute
care beds and icu is increasing this
wave appears to have the most
significant impact on our emergency
departments and inpatient beds
we are not necessarily seeing a spike in
the very ill like we saw in the fall
but we are seeing a surge in people
who may not need icu care but do need
support in emergency departments or in
the hospitals and this is where the real
pressures lie and is currently our focus
i want to talk briefly about the
capacity of our health care system
and what we can do to make sure anyone
who needs hospital care required
receives it regardless of whether they
have coveted or not
as with all ways hhs continues to do all
that we can do to ensure we have enough
hospital capacity
to meet the patient demand
provincially we have about 8 500 beds in
our system
of which about 6 300 of them
called medical surgical beds are
equipped with the staff space and
equipment necessary to care for a
typical covet patient
these types of beds are in communities
all across alberta
and while most towns do not have icu
beds
many will have acute inpatient beds and
very in very general terms these beds
would be used if you needed a hospital
stay
acute care occupancy is always fluid
in urban centers like calgary and
edmonton it can be as high as
90 or even over 100 percent at any given
time while in rural areas acute care
occupancy can be more labile currently
with omicron we are seeing an overall
inpatient occupancy increase
in most areas of the province
and while we still have capacity with
our existing beds we are now working
hard to increase the capacity even
further
we have added an additional 278
net surge inpatient hospital beds and we
have repurposed
883 existing beds so that they can be
used for patients with covet as needed
this does not include icu beds or
specialty beds and while patient numbers
are fluid
there are currently 5
334 non-icu patients
in these acute care hospital beds
that means that provincially
non-icu inpatient occupancy including
additional surge beds is currently at 89
percent
and without the additional surge spaces
provincial icu occupancy would be at 93
percent
this can change really quickly
for example this past weekend the number
of albertans needing hospital care
increased by almost 100 people
our internal early warning system tool
shows that we can expect
hospitalization numbers to keep
increasing for a while yet
and while these patients may not require
the complex icu care it is still really
important to remember that for most
people being in a hospital is a
challenging
a difficult and emotional experience
we need to keep that in mind when we
talk about these numbers
so we are taking measures to increase
capacity while also ensuring we have the
staff
and resources to meet that demand
we proactively planned for a contingency
acute care inpatient spaces in both
edmonton and calgary in earlier waves
and you've heard the premier call these
as pandemic response units
we received funding from the government
of alberta to retrofit shelled spaces we
had at south health campus in calgary
and the edmonton k clinic
these spaces are available when required
on an urgent basis contingent obviously
on staffing availability
and in the incoming days we will be
activating some of these
beds as mentioned the k
clinic unit will open 18 beds in the
coming week with plans to open another
18 beds the week of january 31st
south health campus unit will open 12
beds initially with plans to open
another 12 beds and we will only use
these beds if we have to and going
forward additional beds will be opened
as needed and as staff availability
allows
this temporary measure is one of the
initiatives that will ensure that our
healthcare system can be increased
demand caused by covet 19.
patients moved to a pru can be
recovering from covert 19 and deemed to
be at a low risk of transmitting the
virus or they could be patients with
less complex healthcare needs than those
being cared for in traditional acute
care beds
we cannot just simply open more beds
however it is
not as easy as that you've heard already
the challenges that we have with our
workforce
and it is more of a challenge now than
it has been at any other time during
this pandemic
our teams are understandably exhausted
and as i mentioned many of them are off
sick or isolating themselves
or at home caring for their loved ones
who are also sick
i've been following our absenteeism rate
on a daily basis and note that it has
been high with omicron
about five percent of our staff are sick
at any one time right now
and provincially that comes out to about
5500 staff
this is having an impact on our ability
to fully staff our units and wards and
we know that given any one day
that about 18 to 20 percent of shifts
are being missed due to staff calling in
sick or having to cancel due to other
challenges such as sick family members
and that is very very high for us
we generally run about 15 percent of
shifts missed so we are seeing more
shifts missed in recent weeks
we knew that omicron would impact our
staff with such high covet case numbers
in the community this was expected
and although these numbers provide only
a snapshot in time this is why we have
been putting additional efforts
into bringing on additional staff
as well as increasing staff redeployment
we are also having to deliver health
care differently
in order to meet current patient needs
when necessary we're using an alternate
model of care
this means instead of having individual
health care providers caring for a
smaller number of patients
a team that together has a complete
skill set and relevant experience
collectively
cares for a group of patients
in this very challenging time this is
the best way skilled healthcare teams
can meet the needs of albertans
our staffing models will always be
guided by safety
a team approach to care
and ensuring that staff with the right
skill sets and experience are involved
in looking after albertans
care teams may also have more students
than usual
they are supervised but may be doing
important support tasks in order to
enable more senior members of the care
team
to focus on other clinical needs and we
are so grateful to everyone for stepping
up to help
care teams may also have nurses and
physicians that are from other areas and
may not be as familiar with the area
that they have been reassigned to
these changes are the result of us
having to ramp up the number of beds
available to look after albertans after
two long years
of intensity on the front line
we are so grateful to our team members
our health care workers our physicians
and i personally want to thank you
because saying it too many times is
really not enough
i see the work that you're doing
the ongoing stress
and i'm extremely appreciative
lastly i want to address the question of
surgeries
i know that there's been a lot of
concern
about the possibility of further
surgical postponements and just last
week we were completing
approximately 99 of normal surgical
volumes
this week we know that the postponements
that had to be reduced
surgical volumes to closer to about 90
percent
we are doing all that we can do to
complete as many surgeries and
procedures as possible
but we have had to start postponing
a small number of surgeries as we did in
previous waves
to those albertans who have had
surgeries or procedures postponed
i'm so sorry
and understand how difficult it has been
for you and your loved ones
but this has been necessary to allow us
to create and increase the hospital
capacity
it is also necessary due to the impacts
of staff illness
edmonton and calgary zones began
postponing some scheduled surgeries
yesterday
the numbers are much smaller than we
have seen in previous waves however it
is likely that they will increase we're
also having to postpone some scheduled
surgeries in central zone and north
zones depending on physician and staff
availability
this is very difficult news to share
i understand the anxiety the concerns
and frustrations that every delayed
surgery creates for their patients and
for their loved ones
and again i'm sorry that we find
ourselves in this place again
we will continue
to prioritize urgent surgeries and
procedures as well as cancer and
pediatric surgeries
we do not take the decision
to reduce surgeries and procedures
lightly
and are well aware of the health
implications that any delay in treatment
can cause
as with previous waves it may be
necessary for us also to transfer
patients
to other healthcare or continuing care
facilities to other communities or zones
in order to ensure that all patients get
the care that they need
and while effort is being made to
accommodate a patient and family
preference
this is not always possible given
current systems pressures
please know that this health care system
is here for you
we're doing all that we can for
albertans and this commitment has never
wavered
it's important for people to know that
while our system is definitely stressed
we continue to provide a high level of
care to anyone who needs it
yes we are seeing disruptions to
services
but by our but by and large the vast
majority services
are being provided without fail
the next few weeks are going to be very
difficult but the health care system is
working
it's safe and it's there for albertans
and as with other waves we also need to
help
strongly urge all albertans to get
immonized as quickly as you can please
don't hesitate
the vaccine works it protects you it
protects your loved ones and protects
our communities and it protects our
health care system
please think of the greater good
we need your help in order to ensure
that we are there to help you
and please follow the restrictions
most importantly stay home if you feel
unwell
we need to reduce transmission and we
all need to do that together
as always i want to extend my sincere
heartfelt thanks and gratitude
to all of our incredible healthcare
workers who continue to give it their
all each and every single day
i am proud to work with you
and albertans are lucky to have you
so thank you now passes over to dr
hinshaw
thank you dr you and good afternoon
everyone
turning to today's numbers as the
premier mentioned over the last 24 hours
we have identified 300
3527 new cases of covid19 and completed
about 11 000 tests our positivity rate
is about 33 percent
sadly eight new deaths have been
reported to alberta health over the last
24 hours
these individuals were between the ages
of 56 and 93 and leave behind family
friends and communities
my thoughts are with their loved ones
and anyone else who's grieving a loss
right now no matter the cause
each life lost to this virus reminds us
that covet 19 still presents a real and
present threat in our province
as you have heard over the past few
weeks we have seen an increase of
hospitalizations in all age groups and
this includes children as well
i know this can be concerning for
parents and families
especially since throughout the pandemic
children have made a very up a very low
proportion of hospitalizations
this continues to be the case with four
percent of those who are currently in
hospital with covid under the age of 18.
as with other age groups some of these
children have been admitted for
treatment of covet while others are
being admitted for other reasons and
happen to have a covid19 infection
thankfully evidence from other
jurisdictions indicates that
individually children have a lower risk
of hospitalization for omicron infection
than delta
however the extremely high volume of
cases means that more children are
needing care right now
this is particularly true for those
under one who have always been the
childhood group with the highest risk of
severe outcomes from infection
this is still true with omicron
over the entire pandemic children under
one have had a similar risk of needing
hospital care for covid as adults age 40
to 49 which is dramatically higher than
any other childhood age group
immunization and pregnancy and
immunization of all adults and other
eligible children in contact with
infants is an important way to protect
our young ones
this is yet another example of why it is
important to do everything we can to
slow transmission in our communities get
immunized and stay home and away from
others when we are sick especially away
from those who were too young to be
immunized
as the premier noted earlier it's good
news that health canada has authorized a
new prescription drug product for early
treatment of covid19
our initial supply will be very limited
so it will only be available by
prescription at a small number of
community pharmacies across the province
we are reviewing health canada's
guidelines and working with clinicians
to determine eligibility criteria in
alberta
we want to make sure the drug goes to
those who will benefit the most
especially early on when the supply will
be limited
we expect eligibility will be very
similar to the monoclonal antibodies
cetrovomab including adult albertans
with symptomatic covet infection
confirmed by testing who are at high
risk of progressing to severe disease
we are working to develop the right
pathways for albertans to access both
testing for confirmation of covid
and connections to healthcare
professionals for a clinical assessment
and prescriptions if appropriate
for example patients with kidney disease
or for whom other medications interact
with paxlovit may not be able to take
this medication and that assessment is
important
it's important to be as efficient as
possible with these processes
considering the importance of getting
these drugs to those who will benefit
from them within five days of the onset
of symptoms
we will share this process information
as soon as we can
in the meantime we ask albertans to
please not call their pharmacist or
physician's office until more
information is released
your pharmacist and your physician will
not have any additional information for
you or access to paxlovage before then
i would also like to stress in the
strongest possible way that this
treatment is not a substitute for
vaccination against covid19
unlike paxlovid vaccines are widely
available across the province for anyone
five years of age and older and you
don't need a prescription to get a
vaccine
the best thing you can do to protect
yourself and others from covid19 is to
be vaccinated with as many doses as
you're eligible for as soon as possible
as our hospitalizations rise in this
fifth wave i'm hearing questions about
the vaccination status of patients being
hospitalized because of covid19
it's important for anyone reviewing
hospitalization numbers in the province
by vaccination status to remember that
the number of vaccinated people in
alberta is many many times higher than
the number of unvaccinated people
with the exponential spread of omicron
more people are getting sick than at any
other point in the pandemic so it is not
surprising to see an increase of
hospitalizations
even in some who have been partially or
fully immunized
however as the data shows immunized
individuals are at much less risk of
getting severely ill
for example in the last few months those
who were age 80 or older who have had
three doses of vaccine
have had a lower risk of hospitalization
from covid than unvaccinated 12 to 29
year olds
looking at all age groups combined in
the last several months
those who do not have any vaccine
protection were 15 times more likely to
be hospitalized than those with three
doses
and seven times more likely than those
with two doses
if we look at our current data the
majority of people experiencing the most
severe outcomes and being treated in
intensive care right now are
unvaccinated even though this group
represents a minority of the total
population
specifically unvaccinated individuals
make up only about 10 percent of
alberta's 12 plus population
however unvaccinated people make up over
57 percent of icu patients right now
almost six times their share of the
population
this shows us that vaccines especially
three doses are very effective at
preventing severe illness and death
that's why i continue to urge every
albertan five years of age and older to
get all vaccine doses they are eligible
for
this will not only help to reduce their
risk of severe outcomes from covid19 it
will also help ease the pressure that is
building on our healthcare system and
help every albertan to access the care
they need when they need it thank you
and we're happy to take questions
and doctors that concludes the speaking
portion of today's covet update uh
there's quite a few of you in the queue
today so please keep your questions as
short as possible
and just a reminder of the premier
minister copying and doctors you and
hinshaw are available for questions
operator can you please put through the
first caller
thank you carrie paige global mail
hi thanks for taking my question um
i'm wondering as we see
hospitalization for children go up and
um the rate of absent students go up at
school
how children fit in this
new crunch plan at the hospital how will
their treatment be affected
i think doctor you might be in the best
position to respond
or dr hingel
about schools uh it's about how
pediatric hospitalizations will be
accommodated
yeah so right now um what we've been
doing in terms of following the
pediatric cases is that absolutely as
dr hinshot mentioned
due to the increased
number of children being infected
overall we are seeing a slightly higher
increase
in hospitalizations
the numbers are relatively still small
so
small
right now we have about i think 38
children in the hospital obviously each
hospital is serious and
you know don't underestimate
the
you know the stress and and the trauma
that these children have when they are
hospitalized but right now we are able
to absorb
any covet hospitalizations
for pediatrics
thank you kerry do you have a follow-up
uh yeah i'm a little confused on sort of
the broad strokes of the situation
premiere when we hear you talk you talk
about how
you know you we're at the peak or past
the peak and this won't be as bad as the
last wave because it's not as intense on
icu when we hear doctor you speak
what are we to make of this they're sort
of almost competing narrative
well i i think you you may perhaps
slightly mischaracterize what i said i
said that there are some hopeful signs
but also need for ongoing caution
we see that our wastewater data shows uh
declines in 14 of 19 locations across
the province
most importantly the big cities we have
seen the
stabilization and some early signs of a
reduction in the
uh positivity rate
and
we also know that the typical omicron
wave around the world has lasted about
four weeks we're now into into our fifth
week going into our six weeks so
i think uh you take all of those things
together and it's uh it's reasonable to
infer that we are at or recently passed
the peak of infections
and
when i talked about less severe impact
on the health care system i was really
stressing the icu impact as you'll
recall
during delta with much fewer active
cases
we ended up with i think peaking at
nearly 330 total icu patients
um we're at 200 now we have just a
little over a hundred with covid uh 30
of whom are incidental covet cases
and
from the latest data i've seen
about half of the coveted icu cases are
omicron so assuming that almost all of
our new hospitalizations are omicron
related um you know we can i think
expect to see as other jurisdictions
have
um a relatively low significantly lower
impact on intensive care than earlier
variants particularly delta but i did go
on kerry to point out that
there is significant pressure on the
non-icu side of the system with over a
thousand hospitalizations i said i fully
expect to see over 1500 again 45 of
those are incidental cases
but all of this is complicated by the
fatigue of our work of our fantastic
healthcare workers and uh
and a uh an increase uh in in those who
have had to self-isolate i
it that that increases is is impactful
but it's it's not as bad as we've seen
at other points in the pandemic so i'm
trying to provide a balanced perspective
which is to say
um that there are some very significant
pressures that's why i'm asking
albertans to continue to be a diligent
uh and yet um i am i am hopeful as we've
seen in other parts of the world and
other parts of canada hit earlier by
omicron that we'll start to see the case
numbers come down the positivity rate
come down
and eventually that that probably means
uh peaking in healthcare uh use
later this month and then hopefully a
decline in health care pressure
thank you premier operator can you
please put through the next caller
thank you andrew lawton true north
good afternoon premier you raised i
think a very important question and
answered it earlier about how long we
will be saddled with restrictions but
i'm hoping to get a bit more detail from
you than just very soon for lifting them
we had in ontario for example a road map
updated today that has by march still no
uh revocation of mass mandates no
replication of factory passports
realistically how long are you prepared
to keep those two things in place in
alberta and to get more specific with it
what are the metrics that you'll use to
inform when to lift those
well we won't consider
lifting the current measures
until we see
a
sustained decline in pressure on
hospitalization that would follow a
sustained decline in new cases of course
so
um
you know i think it would be fair to say
andrew that if we expect to see
hospitalizations peak
towards the end of this month beginning
of february uh that we need to see
sustained decline in that hospital
pressure before we could move forward uh
with considering relaxation of measures
prudently look i i would just point out
andrew that alberta
like much of western canada has
maintained
uh much less severe restrictions than
parts of central and eastern canada
and yet
we have so far been less severely
impacted by omicron there may be a lot
of reasons for that we had a bigger
delta wave here that may have created
more people with with immunity from
prior infection there may be a lot of
reasons for it
but
what i can tell you is i am eager i am
eager
for us to be able to uh
stop
some of these incredible intrusions in
people's lives
um
and increasingly i think that the data
we're seeing around the world uh points
hopefully to the ability to do that
but uh we've got to stick to our
knitting right now uh we are at our you
know we are expecting probably a few
hundred more people in our hospitals
with kovitz so it's too early for us uh
to plan for relaxation of measures at
this point
thank you premier and andrew do you have
a follow-up
i do you've been very clear premiere
that you uh will not advance the fact
the mandate you've been very critical of
the quebec government's attempt to exact
a health contribution as they call it a
fine on the unvaccinated yet you were
also unequivocal when it came to
criticizing the idea of acting passports
before uh you implemented those in
alberta so i mean where's the
accountability measure to ensure that if
things don't get bad this may not be
something that is on the table in
alberta
fair question
i i would point out that every uh
premier including the prime minister
were opposed to proof of vaccination
requirements in the spring our
collective experience on delta
uh hit us hard and and for us the
alternative to shutting down businesses
was um a proof of vaccination program
i um
uh when it comes to the quebec policy i
spoke very bluntly about that last week
uh i would just point out uh andrew that
this our government
through the legislature last year
repealed
the
power
for the government to force mandatory
vaccination on people
and that's a power that had been in the
law since i gather 1910
so we took that out of the law we no
longer have no longer have the power
should any government in the future want
to god forbid to um
take away people's bodily autonomy in
that way
uh uh in terms of that the health care
levy
or whatever quebec is calling it um
again i just think this is um
what can i tell you uh i'd be happy to
propose a law in the legislature this
spring to say that this is not uh
legally possible in alberta i
it it to me
um
the the idea of sending people a bill
effectively even if it's indirectly
doing that for their health care
is a total violation of the universality
of our public publicly funded system
and you know when we have people who
make bad life choices
who
um
when we have
people with
drug addictions who show up in the
emergency ward frequently we don't ask
for their credit card we don't send them
a bill
we do the compassionate thing we don't
judge them we care for them
when a drunk driver shows up at the
hospital uh the same thing
when uh
you know a
uh
a criminal
gets uh
into a fight and gets injured they show
up at the hospital we don't judge them
because of the choices they made we care
for them that's the canadian system
that's certainly the alberta system and
as long as this government's an officer
will continue to be
thank you premier operator can you
please put through the next caller
thank you carolyn dunn cbc
uh thank you very much for taking my
question um this is a little off topic
from koben but we have been told that
senior members of your staff and cabinet
uh knew about uh the
minister
madhu distracted driving tickets
the day after it happened and i'm
wondering if you can tell me when did
you know and why wasn't it addressed
sooner
you know i do recall at some point last
year hearing the minister matthew had
gotten a ticket had paid for it
i got fully briefed on all of this
including about the call and the details
on monday afternoon following media
inquiries
i i
shortly thereafter i called minister
madhu
to ask what happened from his
perspective and why he made this call
expressed my serious disappointment that
he would have done this
he said to me essentially what he has
said in his public statements i asked my
chief of staff to call
chief mcphee
to get his account or recollection of
this call
that had he had received from minister
madhu
and again my understanding is he he said
essentially the same thing to my chief
of staff as he said publicly in media
reports
i
now because the chief has said
that
well just to quote he said quotes to be
very clear he never asked me about the
ticket
his concern what was happening in
lethbridge concerned around what was
going on in relation to people of color
being stopped
and
because of the context of some of those
issues i
reached out to a number of
respected
former
leaders in the judiciary
in government and in policing
on monday
afternoon and evening to get their
advice on on how best to address this
and
the consensus of the several uh
uh people that with whom i spoke
respected former leaders of of
government and and the judiciary was uh
that having a third party investigation
to identify exactly what happened would
be the right approach to determine
whether there was
any effort to interfere in the
independent administration of justice
and that is why i announced on monday
that we will be appointing um a
independent investigator
to look into exactly that question
we have drafted terms of reference we
have contacted some former members
respected members of the judiciary to
see if they would have the time
to to
assist with this kind of investigation
uh and i hope to be able to have more to
report on that in the very near future
thank you premier carolyn do you have a
follow-up
i do actually so um the review is one
thing what would the consequences be if
wrongdoing is found and why didn't you
just fire him
right away and then reinstate him if he
is cleared in some review
well i've looked at precedence such as
this where
uh you know when i was minister of
defense for example and we had a a
senior officer um with the serious
allegations made against them uh the
typical response would be to
put that person on a leave of absence uh
conduct an investigation
to determine the facts
and then to make a final decision about
their situation i think that is normal
in in a context like this let me say
this if
um chief mcphee
had alleged
that
he felt this was a interference in the
administration of justice the
independence of the police or
an effort to rescind the ticket if
i would have
made a uh immediate decision
uh
to remove mr maddie from cabinet but um
that's not the public statement that we
have
questions have been raised about
profiling i was not on this call
i was not
present at the time that this ticket was
issued
and i think given the issues that have
been raised
it is appropriate
to
allow for a little bit of time for an
investigation
from
somebody with
legal training who is impartial
to provide me with advice on uh whether
this constituted uh a uh an effort to
interfere in the independent
administration of justice so that's what
we're doing
as i said um i reached out to a number
of
nearly a dozen
senior former members of both
the judiciary and of government to get
their advice and that was the consensus
view of the people who who gave me
advice last monday and and i think it
again it's conventional with similar
circumstances that i've seen
thank you premier operator can you
please put through the next caller
still in short post media
hi there i'd like to go back to
children in hospital i know that they
still represent a smaller number than
their older counterparts but between
december 31st and yesterday it looks
like there were 160 admissions for
children under the age of 19. the same
time frame from last year was 35 so i
guess my question is
given the increase in the number of
children that are going to hospital with
clovis what's being done i guess to
protect this population especially given
the fact that they aren't eligible for a
booster shot yet
um
so perhaps dr hinshaw dr you
um
so perhaps dr hinshaw dr you
so i can speak to population protection
and i just want to make sure i
understand um so you're speaking about
the under five population or you're
speaking about the under 18 or i guess
it would be the under 12 population who
would be coming due for their second
doses in the next several weeks or or
all of them together just to clarify
yeah sorry i guess all of them together
but especially for the individuals that
haven't been able to get fully immunized
yet
so absolutely the number of children
currently in hospital as dr you
mentioned each of those children
would
have a significant impact on them and on
their family
and that should not be discounted
it is also true that the
percentage of cases that
are going to hospital when we look at
the evidence around the world about
omicron is a lower risk this is
unfortunately the consequence of the
significant transmission we're seeing
right now
it's absolutely critical that anyone who
is in a household with or interacts
regularly with someone who is in this
younger age group
receive their vaccines as soon as
possible it's clear that children who
live in a household
where all adults are fully immunized
have a lower risk of ending up in
hospital than children who live in a
household where not all adults are fully
immunized it's also true that those
children under one have the absolute
highest risk of all childhood age groups
and it's
really important that those who are
pregnant access the protection of
vaccine for themselves and for their
children
it's also critical again that all of us
do everything we can to minimize
transmission in the community so that we
can lower the chances of children being
exposed
but we do know again that
the higher numbers are due to the higher
transmission that we're seeing right now
and that protecting kids is really
something all of us can do together
the last time i looked at the data i
didn't see that any children with a
single dose of vaccine had been admitted
so even in that 5 to 11 year old age
group it's important to note that at
least the last time i checked we hadn't
seen
any
kids who were at least partially
vaccinated ending up in hospital it is
of course important for those children
to receive their booster and and most
who were early in the first dose will be
coming due for that very soon
so i encourage those parents to get
their kids fully vaccinated in that 5 to
11 year old age group but again it's
it's the vaccination of those around
them that is going to really be
important at minimizing risk
take your doctor and dylan do you have a
follow-up
yeah i do i'm not sure who this would be
directed towards but
in in recent weeks past months or so
we've seen the rollback of pcr testing
so children can't receive those if they
may have access to rapid tests through
their schools but many still do not
um
there's now no school outbreak reporting
um online at least officially
i'm hearing from a lot of parents if
they feel that they can't make safe
decisions for their children i would
like to get a response
to that to parents that feel that they
can't make an informed safe decision
on what's best for the children
we've been used to
having access to pcr testing for mild
illness in all age groups for almost two
years
and so it's really difficult when we've
been used to having that access when
we've been used to having
all of the outbreak data all of the case
data
the the shift that omicron has required
us to make is difficult especially over
a short time period so i sympathize with
parents who want the kind of information
they used to have
what is important to understand about
our current omicron wave is that
even though again our cases may be at a
plateau right now transmission is
incredibly high so if parents are trying
to decide what activities their children
should
engage in they need to understand that
there's a high likelihood
that there could be someone infectious
at almost any activity their children
participate in outside the home
which is exactly why in schools we've
ensured that there are additional levels
of protection with medical masks and
regular access to rapid testing for
asymptomatic screening in that context
and it is important for parents then to
understand they need to make the the
risk-based decisions that are
appropriate for their family based on
community spread at this time
because we simply
must use our access to testing for those
who need it for clinical reasons and for
those high-risk settings where the risk
of severe outcomes is very high such as
long-term care
thank you dr henshaw operator can you
please put through the next copy
brianna carson schmidt global news
hi there i think my question is for dr
you uh dr you i'm asking about the uh i
guess back sale for your
staff in order to fill these beds in
this new phone line we're hearing that
uh corporate or out of scope staff will
be taking on some other duties uh can
you talk about that and then i guess for
the premier why aren't you
asking either other provinces or the
military to step in and also bring an
extra hand
yeah so in terms of the first part of
the question absolutely anybody who has
any clinical experience
no matter what position they work in
within the organization we're actually
asking for their skill sets
what they've done in the past and
finding appropriate redeployment
positions for them i just want to say
thank you to our teams who have been
redeployed
for over two years and just to say it's
very difficult
to be redeployed into areas where you're
not familiar with and
you know our teams have just continued
to go above and beyond the call of duty
all the time when it comes to staffing
so i just second part of the question um
which was
why have i not called upon the canadian
military or other provinces to help us
out
well the answer is
that every province is stretched in
right now for exactly the same reasons
in fact alberta
has a lower uh per capita rate of
hospitalization from covet 19 than
canada as a whole and much lower than
for example uh ontario and quebec
so uh other provinces do not have spare
capacity
they're all stretched as as has every
part of the world i mean even the us
which spends a lot more
on health care and has uh relatively
more health care workers per capita uh
even many of their hospital systems have
been stretched for the same reasons
um and in terms of the canadian armed
forces the canadian armed forces as i've
pointed out before has extremely limited
um health
capacity they don't actually run a
hospital system anymore that ended about
25 years back
and when we did call on the uh forces
through the federal government for some
help back in
september for delta
they were able i think my recollection
was to provide nine
nurses
which
which helped us to maybe staff one or
two beds
in icu so
um and though and those assets have been
those individuals have been redeployed
to provinces that are harder hit so the
feds with their very limited health care
assets have to go to where the needs are
greatest i think right now that would be
quebec
which despite its curfew and lockdown
policies has been hardest hit province
in canada from omicron
thank you premier operator can you
please put through our final color
thank you audrey nimble radio canada
hi thank you for taking my question i'll
just start with a question in french on
something you've already been asked on
the this way
because
[Music]
[Music]
uh
thank you premier and audrey do you have
a follow-up
uh yes
was it oh
thank you everyone that concludes
today's press conference